bonjour pierre emmanuel thomann merci
beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin avec
nous sur rt france vous êtes vous êtes
en hongrie à budapest comment est-ce que
cette initiative diplomatique d'emmanuel
macron est perçue du côté de chez vous
plutôt bien perçu parce que les hongrois
comme tous les pays membres de l'union
européenne
sont en faveur d'une désescalade et
surtout d'éviter un conflit avec la
russie ce n'est dans l'intérêt de
personne
donc les hongrois aussi ont une
politique d' équilibre avec le président
or ban entre états unis
la russie
les différents états membres de l'union
européenne l'allemagne et la france et
donc c'est pas il est parfaitement
compréhensible pour les pour les
hongrois que l'europe aussi essaye de se
mettre en avant pour ne pas se faire
dicter leur leur positionnement parler
les pays anglo saxons qui sont beaucoup
plus agressif vis-à-vis de la russie les
états unis et le royaume uni seulement
l'europe joue ce rôle de fusible entre
les atlantistes anglo saxons si je puis
dire et et la russie
exactement
alors la france avec sa tradition
gaulliste
essaye de positionner
les européens
médiateur est évidemment pour la france
c'est une opportunité pour
la re jouer le rôle de chef de file en
europe et c'est ce qu'essaie de jouer le
le président français emmanuel macron un
petit peu à l'image de nicolas sarkozy
qui avait joué les médiateurs lors de la
guerre en vue entre la russie et la
géorgie en 2008 alors il est dommage que
ce positionnement viennent un petit peu
tard car lorsque la preuve la russie
avait fait des propositions décembre
pour négocier banc d'une part avec les
états unis et d'autre part avec l'otan
c'était l'occasion tout de suite de
saisir cette perche tendue par les
russes pour négocier une nouvelle
architecture de sécurité
que qui est dans l'intérêt de la france
depuis extrêmement longtemps et il faut
savoir que dans la géopolitique globale
la proche des états unis c'est de
fragmenter l'europe c'est d'un côté
la stratégie au pacifique contre la
chine et le front oriental contre la
russie parce que les états unis estiment
que pour se préparer à affronter la
chine ils doivent réduire le rôle de la
russie et en particulier faire de la
russie un adversaire parce que si la
russie n'est plus un adversaire pour les
européens eh bien il n'a plus de rôle
pour l'otan et ils perdent leur leur
leur levier d'influencé vis-à-vis des
européens donc il y a il ya un intérêt
commun entre les membres de l'union
européenne à éviter cette escalade et il
faut voir aussi que c'est faire pression
sur l'ukraine qui ne met pas en oeuvre
les accords de 2006 précisément parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas régionaliser le
pays
afin de donner une autonomie en dôme bas
ce qui bloquerait évidemment la voie
vers l'adhésion de l'otan et les états
unis aussi ne veulent pas signé de
traité car n'y a pas accord sur
l'ordre spatiale ordre géopolitique dans
le monde où il pense toujours peut-être
un jour après un changement de régime en
russie une évolution toujours faire
avancer l'otan plus proche des
frontières de la russie et étendre leur
propre zone d' influence alors derrière
lui est le positionnement des européens
il ya évidemment s'ils sont tous
d'accord pour éviter un conflit personne
ne peut de guerre avec la russie il y à
des positionnements différents la france
et pour depuis longtemps une
architecture open de sécurité avec un
rapprochement puis sensible avec la
russie comme facteur d'équilibré tandis
que les allemands sont beaucoup plus
atlantiste et considère que l'union
européenne n'est qu'un sous-ensemble de
l'espace euro atlantique et les polonais
évidemment sont beaucoup plus en faveur
de la position américaine mais on voit
là que quand même il y à un
rapprochement h à court terme pour
éviter un conflit le problème c'est de
se positionner à plus long terme sur une
nouvelle architecture de vos peines de
six cultes et ça ce sera extrêmement
difficile qu'avec des positions
divergentes y compris au sein de l'union
européenne alors le président obama a
rencontré récemment également le
président vladimir poutine
emmanuel macron à parler de garanties
pour poursuivre les négociations il
s'est dit plutôt optimiste pour une
possibilité de faire avancer les
négociations entre la russie et
l'ukraine est-ce que c'est aussi le
sentiment du président organes
oui bien sûr parce que là la hongrie par
rapport si on le compare aux autres pays
d'europe centrale et orientale en
particulier la pologne et les pays
baltes et favorable justement un
meilleur équilibre entre l'espace
atlantique et la relation avec la russie
est donc là il y à une accord entre la
france et la hongrie sur
cette nécessité de d'éviter une
fragmentation de l'europe qui est
malheureusement promu par la vision
géopolitique des anglo saxons vous vous
croyez à un sommet prochain et les
ukrainiens disent qu'il y aurait
peut-être un sommet justement avec la
russie sur le format normandie ce serait
peut-être l'issue de cette crise
alors ce serait une étape évidemment
le problème c'est que il y à la question
de court terme qui est d'éviter
le conflit et il faut savoir aussi que
malheureusement lui l'armée ukrainienne
bombarde le donbass eux régulièrement il
ya une guerre de basse intensité et on
n'en parle pas beaucoup dans les médias
européens de l'ouest et il s'agit aussi
de faire pression sur l'ukraine et ce
sera difficile parce que derrière il y
aller les etats unis qui soutiennent le
cren comme un proxy un état
à détacher de la russie justement pour
affaiblir la russie et créer une
fragmentation entre les pays de l'union
européenne et la russie afin de
maintenir leur suprématie en europe et
dans le monde et donc que peut faire
l'europe pour inciter les les états unis
à la retenue
alors justement c'est de mettre en avant
les intérêts des européens mais ils
auraient dû le faire depuis longtemps
depuis beaucoup plus longtemps et c'est
parce que les les membres de l'union
européenne sont divisés en particulier
allemande et la france sur un
positionnement de claire
une position totalement différente des
etats-unis au
sein de l'otan il aurait dû il exprimé
depuis longtemps et c'est pour ça que
cette crise
est arrivée à un point des escalades
inacceptable ce sera plus facile je
pense d'arriver à un accord peut-être
précaire pour éviter le conflit où le
modèle et je dirais l'endiguer mais un
accord sur une architecture open de
sécurité ce sera beaucoup plus difficile
je pense qu'on est entré dans une phase
de crise extrêmement longue et tant qu'
il n'y a pas accord sur l'ordre
géopolitique mondiale qui permettrait à
un multilatéralisme
plus efficace tant que les états unis
n'acceptent pas pleinement le monde
multipolaire et leur et leurs alliés les
plus proches aussi la pologne les pays
baltes il est qu'ils veulent toujours
désigné la russie comme un adversaire
afin de faire pression sur les européens
et préserver leur positionnement et les
l'otan en europe il sera extrêmement
difficile d'avoir de mettre en oeuvre
cette nouvelle architecture européenne
de syrie sécurité mais pour le
positionnement des européens c'est
indispensable à l'avenir mais je pense
que là il y a l'otan et l'union
européenne ne sont pas capables de
s'unir et donc il est utile de faire des
coalitions plus restreinte d'états
membres de l'union européenne et de
l'otan voir avec d'autres et à peut-être
à l'extérieur
pour essayer de faire mon poids et
influencer ces organisations qui sont
obsolètes le lieu européenne et l'otan
ont été créés pendant la guerre froide
et malheureusement elles ont toujours ce
positionnement de rivalité avec la
russie ce qui ne correspond plus je
pense pour les intérêts des européens en
ce 21ème siècle merci beaucoup pierre
emmanuel thomann de nous avoir livré
votre point de vue depuis budapest ce
matin